heaven
and heav
[Applause]
[Music]
and hello everybody from Fox
Square the All-American Christmas tree
is back and it's better than ever and
boy are we excited to officially kick
off the holiday season this time of the
year it's all about faith family and
friends it's also about making new
memories and we plan on doing that
tonight Jesse we can't wait to press
that button and see this amazing tree
light up it stands 50 feet tall and is
made right here in America it took 27
hours to put it all together this symbol
of Christmas with three
40,000 lights 12,000 ornaments that sat
on 500 branches and it is topped with a
six foot tall
star it's good it's good to have
everyone back around the tree we have a
big big show ah head pack with many
surprises our favorite Fox host and
their families as well as well as all
Fox employees or a lot of them are all
here to celebrate and the holiday season
always reminds us to remember what is
most important this year the fox family
is thinking of Israel and the Jewish
people believe me we hear you and we are
standing with you it has been a
heart-wrenching 44 days since Hamas
terrorists launched an attack on the
Israeli people more than 200 are still
being held hostage including babies as
young as 10 months old and we are all
hoping and praying that their families
get to hug them again very soon
this Christmas Fox news media is
partnering with the First Responders
Children's Foundation they provide
support to families who have lost a
parent in the line of duty across the
country Fox employees are helping out by
donating 1,000 gifts and they wrapped
every single one of them I don't believe
that so are so are you guys ready yeah
all
right let's let the festivities begin
I'm pretty excited I think it well first
of all you all look great
everybody looks great you sound great
and it I remember last year this really
became for me the kickoff to the
Christmas season absolutely I mean now
it's time to get the tree out and to
make sure that you put great decorations
on it but not as many as this well I
think Harold's had his tree up for about
a month right Harold we go we go early
we go right after Halloween we put the
Christmas lights up we'll do Christmas
tree probably in a few days but I got to
tell you coming up and down 6th Avenue
and seeing that thing lit up uh is going
to make a lot of Americans happy and a
lot of New York is happy all right that
was amazing you like my sweater we love
your sweater love your sweater you can
get that at the fox shop Fox is the best
ugly
sweater well lighting the all- American
Christmas tree would not be complete
without a few blessings Chief religion
correspondent Lauren Green she is here
and she has religious leaders with her
to kick us off tonight hi Lauren hey
Dana well you know this time of year we
celebrate the miracle of light of light
overcoming Darkness uh for Jews it is
the Festival of Lights which is Hanukkah
the Marvel of one day oil lasting eight
days and for Christians it is Christmas
the birth of Jesus who is called the
light of the world and uh the lighting
the All-American Christmas tree would
not be complete without a few blessings
and to start us off is the Reverend
Lawrence acre from Cornerstone Baptist
Church in Brooklyn
Reverend good evening let us
pray God of Light and love in the
darkness of winter you bring joy to our
hearts with the lighting of this tree
may your light shine within our hearts
throughout these days and fill us we
pray with the hope of peace on Earth and
Good Will to
all Jesus the light of the world as we
celebrate your birth may we begin to see
the world in the light of understanding
in you give us as you chose the lowly
the outcast and the poor to receive the
greatest news the world has ever known
so may we worship you in the meekness of
heart that you give may we also remember
our brothers and sisters less fortunate
than ourselves in this season of giving
in a world where worry not peace
prevails stir up that good news again
this Christmas make it real in our
hearts
never have we needed your joy and peace
more than now thank you for the gift of
Jesus our Emmanuel the word made flesh
amen amen amen thank you so much
Reverend AER Rabbi um hasal Lin is here
your thoughts on what must be a very
challenging holiday season for Jews
around the
world it's a great honor for me to be
with Reverend an an AER
and especially with Cardinal Dolan whom
I have respected for years ever since he
ascended to the Cardinal
ship uh a great religious
leader and to be here at this moment
when the tree the Christmas tree on the
Avenue of the
Americas is
dedicated what a wonderful thing in the
Public Square to have a religious
symbol I'm in favor of religion in
America America is founded on the
biblical
tradition the biblical tradition of the
prophet Micah who stated what does God
want of us but to do
justice to dispense kindness and to walk
humbly with
God the biblical tradition that says
that when the human being was
created he was created as one the other
species were
numbers but only one human being was
created and the talmud says the lesson
from that is twofold number one from one
person came a whole world and therefore
every human life has infinite value and
number two nobody can say my ancestor
was more important than your ancestor
because we all have a common
ancestor
Adam and therefore I say to my Christian
brothers and
sisters Merry Christmas to you and to
all Americans I
say may we be able to live together in a
land and as a
nation
undivided
indivisible under god with liberty and
justice for all amen amen amen Rabbi
thank you so much Rabbi Lon and now
Timothy Cardinal Dolan the Archbishop of
New York uh here to share his Blessing
on on the all- American Christmas tree
thank you Lauren Rabbi Reverend let us
pray Lord Our God we praise you for the
light of creation the Sun the moon the
stars of the night we praise you for the
light of Israel the law the prophets and
the wisdom of the scriptures we praise
you for Jesus Christ your son he is
Emmanuel God With Us the Prince of Peace
who fills us with wonder and love so
Lord God let your blessing come upon us
as we illumin this tree this evening May
the light and cheer it gives this city
be a sign of the joy that fills our
hearts may all who Delight in this tree
come to the knowledge and joy of
Salvation through Christ Our Lord amen
Allelujah thank you Lord Cal Dolan thank
you so much and to all the leaders up
here thank you so much Dana back to you
Lauren thank you so much Lauren Green
and our religious leaders we appreciate
you and we are are getting closer to
lighting our All-American Christmas tree
what do you know
Jesse okay let me stand next to here
Brett Bear and family Amy if I can just
squeeze
in and we have the boys here Brett tell
us what the Christmas season means in
your household well it means family time
and this place is all about family you
know you look around and a lot of fox
people have their families here and
listening to those prayers that's really
what this is all about so that's what it
means does Brett do a lot of decorating
at home I would say Brett is very
cheerful around the holidays decorating
maybe not even more cheerful than he
already is very diplomatic thank you
honey Merry
Christmas okay where is Shannon bream
the author of one of the best selling
books of all time women of the Bible
this is a very special season for you
tell us the religious aspect and in your
household well it really is the greatest
gift we have so many faiths that are
celebrating right now wonderful to hear
from our leaders of different faiths um
but really the idea that God would
become a human and walk this flawed
planet with us to redeem us is such a
hopeful message and I know holidays
aren't always easy for everybody but
there is hope there is inspiration and I
just cling to that it is a flawed Planet
but we're going to turn that around
where's Rosanna here we are by the way I
have a reservation at your place next
week so I I expect to see you in a good
mood what do we cook on Christmas in
your household well of course the night
of seven fishes of course yeah I mean
right Janine judge Janine she knows it
takes a lot of love a lot of patience
and um we have a seat at the table for
you Jesse okay I might have to take you
up on that where is our friend Brian
right behind okay Brian here we are here
we are a lot of shopping in the
Christmas season is this going to be a
big spending time of year I hope so
because I think Timmy might have brought
his Christmas list with him to give to
you and you could really spend for Timmy
couldn't you this year I'm Mr Claus the
season right here yeah no it's great I
mean like giving gifts is wonderful
because it's it's part of the whole
family tradition of caring for one
another celebrating together the
greatest gift that man has ever known
God With Us um and so yeah just an
awesome season to give generously and
joy okay I'll take the list after the
show where's
Ansley anley let me shimmy my way down
there now you have a beautiful family
what does it mean for the children for
the children it means Jesus baby Jesus
definitely who we learn about every
night but also Santa Claus she's clearly
excited about that we already have our
list and it means family just being
together with family and our loved ones
and it's not always easy for many
families but we have hope because of of
Jesus Christ and you know we all grew up
in different cities and now we're
working at Fox News and we watch tree
lighting ceremonies and the Thanksgiving
Day Parade and now we're living our
Dream here in New York so thank you
Suzanne thank you Jay for that um it's
just I just it's so surreal that I'm
standing outside of Fox News my dream
was to be in New York City with my
daughter so um I can't I'm so grateful
what a blessing oh God bless you and
dreams do come
true what do we have now we have Nick I
believe the weatherman who's tapping me
on the shoulder is it going to be a
white Christmas uh it will be there will
be some sort of weather on Christmas yes
yes good prediction thank you thank you
uh listen I love Christmas I'm a lover
and a giver and I believe in my heart of
hearts there's no better present you
could give yourself than downloading the
fox weather app this
year it's free it's always on and we're
on every connected TV smart device that
you have so Jolly Old St Nick to the
rescue here Jesse a Christmas plug and
it's great to have all you guys here
with us tonight it couldn't be complete
though without our Christmas
correspondent Jimmy
failure hey hey hey it is freezing out
here in New York City but this crowd is
fired up listen to them come
[Applause]
alive it might be cold but New Yorkers
like it because that means we can't
smell the city and and let's be honest
the lighting of the Fox News Christmas
tree means it is time for Santa and
everybody loves Santa and I right New
York
City now the kids love Santa because he
brings him presents the adults love
Santa because he's our only friend who's
not on OIC but but we are out here to
cheer him on with a bunch of big TV
stars who look like TV stars and a guy
like me who looks like he installed your
TV merry Christmas everybody from the
Christmas correspondent Jim
fa over to you Greg Gutfeld oh oh what
are you guys wearing well I have a
beautiful new scarf it is very white and
blue Greg it's very holiday colors
matches sweater think that you can get
these in the fox shop yes well you you
taking that home I hope so you know what
you're going to do you're going to
regift that aren't
you yes Dad I'm sorry now you know
what's under the tree already it har
it's great to be back with you and a
scarf good to be back around the table
outdoors look I thought with the the the
religion thank you guys for what you
said and reminding us of what this
holiday is about to the Cardinal and to
the rabbi and to the pastor saying let
us remember the least and the last and
the most vulnerable as we go through
this season as well so thank you well
that's the she's the least vulnerable
judge well what do you want to ask me oh
when are you going to exchange that
scarf for that one um as soon as I get
off camera I'm going to be wearing this
but here's the good news that sweater
that you have on you open your jacket
it's going to fly off the shelves go
ahead
open it's very subtle you see the F FX
Fox News
what what right excuse me c job
Greg I said Fox yes definitely Fox News
all right here we go all right we're
just minutes away from lighting this 50
foot Christmas masterpiece and we have a
big surprise you won't want to miss when
we come back with the All American
Christmas tree lighting presented by the
[Applause]
five hey Sean Hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to Fox News YouTube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else